a wallet-sized card that holds into a
knife and now you can shred while you
shred it's episode three of loot do you
want a t-shirt that says I love shirts
we'll grab this shirt that cuts right to
the chase or get a hat that says I hate
my head not creepy enough for you then
buy yourself an augmented reality made
your computer in your webcam recognize
the cubes surfaces and displays a girl
on your screen that you can interact
with by taking off her clothes if your
imaginary digital girlfriend gets you
hot put on your USB powered air
conditioned shirt and inside your unused
USB ports plug in some of these flash
drives skateboards surfboards
transformers and this Nano drive that
barely exists but can hold eight
gigabytes of data cuddle up with a cute
crochet zombie doll complete with bloody
guts and sawed off limbs unless it's not
enough about you in that case send a
photo of yourself to I am a stuffed
animal calm there artist will design you
and your own cuddly toy so you can
finally sleep with yourself inside a
giant shark sleeping bag that's my face
comm goes even further they'll turn a
photo of you or someone you know into an
actual action figure or an origami photo
mask you can print off and fold into
yourself are you trying to sneak wine
around without getting caught are you a
girl
then throw on the wine rack it holds 25
ounces of wine and gives you support
think geek brings us chocolate without
the calories there whiff lets you inhale
chocolate or coffee flavor without
actually eating anything as your
waistline disappears so will this table
every time someone orders it a pixel is
removed from the design making each new
table unique and after enough are
ordered the table will cease to exist
these gold-plated bracelets are lined
with ethical fur the artist finds and
skins roadkill luna and curious is sold
out of them but go ahead and grab some
fake floral eyelashes now it's time for
things I actually bought this week in a
regular IQ cube that works like a normal
3 by 3 by 3 but turns at angles into
shapes like these and a foursome
conjoined two by two by two all I need
now is this Rubik's Cube table these
utensils that are also tools were sent
to me by a
Saucer just like you you can submit cool
things that you find that can be
purchased over at facebook.com slash
vsauce gaming oh and by the way the same
company also makes a bolt Bowl which is
perfect for someone like you who's a nut
I leave you today with a chairman at of
stuffed pandas the most luxurious
material to get comfortable in be sure
to subscribe to Vsauce 2 for more loot
and boat and let me know in the comments
below what do you want a chair made out
of and as always thanks for watching